there's an app where literally everyone
stops what they're doing there's no
filter and you take a picture and you
have your friends and you can't see what
your other friends post until you choke
so it's kind of giving you incentive to
post so you can see and interact with
others on the app so if you don't post
that day you can't see what your other
friends are doing and there's no filter
and it's a front and back camera view of
what you're doing it shows your
surroundings and a selfie whoa I'm gonna
do one what's the point of it uh it's
basically it's kind of a response into
social media feeding you [ __ ] you don't
follow whereas this is you're only
seeing your friends actually what
they're doing and there's no cool yeah
so the king understanding is be real the
app right now I take a picture of you
guys and you're on it too he takes a
picture of me
so so it goes like that see wow oh wow
that's cool and then you can switch to
the looks you know oh wow and so then
only your friends are commenting and
[ __ ] like that and that's it and it's
like a feed of one picture a day yeah
just one a day yeah and then you have
other people and then you see what it is
oh I like that it's kind of cool yeah
it's it's blown up too yeah
oh yeah because I'm like oh say less
yeah well then you're real first I'm
gonna ask hey can we buy this yeah and
they're gonna be like no you can't buy
it they're gonna be like this okay
they're not even gonna ask can we buy it
they're gonna do it hey real quick does
be real Shadow band you like Instagram
because I'm Shadow band on Instagram can
you do naughty things right right gotcha
so I can't be too real I love you know
that there's somebody who didn't know
they take the front facing camera and
they were like at the strip club and
they were just like oh [ __ ] watch it I
guess then you see naked chicks on it
and that's naughty so okay
stay real girl you know what one thing
about that that girl she was really [ __ ]
I think if you're being real and I'm
being real with you she's too real but I
mean I'm just saying maybe be real has a
thing where it's like this person is
just too real like something from the
streets that's like the paid version is
too real
you know what I mean too real yeah
my only thing is like so be be real
how's that different than Instagram just
that it takes you a picture a selfie of
you and part of it is that you're
supposed there's one notification a day
and you're supposed to post within two
minutes you can do it later oh it'll be
like real oh it'll post like do it now
yeah and then you have to do it within
two minutes or you like get kicked out
no no it sounds stressful you don't get
kicked out you just post later and then
people know you're not being real right
and so I was [ __ ] or something yeah
and so if it gives you the notification
you're like at work you gotta post there
to show you like your real life yeah oh
that's interesting how interesting I'm
seriously if I only had it two days at
both the times I was like say same spot
on my couch and I was like I don't want
to do this but I did and that's real
I want in